Okay, so
how do these magic hash functions work?
The purpose of a hash function is to
transform some value into one that can
be stored and retrieved easily.
You give it some value, it converts
the value based on some formula, and
spits out a coded version of the value
that's often the index in an array.
Let's go through an example
to clarify this process.
Let's say you're running some big event.
Maybe it's for
people who like a certain type of music.
Everybody who wants to come to the event
needs to buy tickets in advance.
All of those tickets are randomly
numbered, and those numbers are embedded
in bar codes on physical tickets that
people hand you when they first arrive.
You need to be able to look up ticket
numbers fast when people check in at
the event.
Storing the ticket number in one of
those incredible hash functions sounds
pretty great to you.
You have all of your numbers,
now you just need to come up with
a hash function to convert them to hash
values so they can be stored easily.
One common pattern in hash functions
is to take the last few digits of a big
number, divide it by some
consistent number, and using
the remainder from that division to find
a place to store that number in a array.
In this case, the remainder turned
directly into the index of an array.
Why does this strategy work?
Well, if the numbers we had assigned
to each ticket were 0 to 100,
we could easily store it all in an array
and look them up instantly by the index.
When numbers are big and
random like the ones we started with,
we need some way to convert those
numbers into array indices quickly.
That's how the constant
time lookup works.
You give your number to a hash function,
which spits out a hash code that
turns into the index of an array.
You can go to your array and
get your original value in constant time
since an array look up with
an index happens in constant time.
Hm, why use the last few
digits of a big number?
In most cases the last few
digits are the most random.
If you're assigning your
numbers in numerical order
The first few digits
really wouldn't be random.
They're more likely to start with a 1,
a 2,
a 3, etc,
than later numbers like 7, 8, or 9.